[Music]
our top story at the bottom of the hour
president Trump has canceled a trip to a
summit meeting in South America to focus
on the US response to last weekend's
alleged chemical attack on Syrian rebels
the president is calling Syrian leader
Bashar al-assad an animal he's also
accusing Russian President Vladimir
Putin of complicity well now a look back
at policy correspondent Richardson shows
us how we got to this point from the
State Department tonight
it began with protests in 2011 and it
drags on the Syrian civil war has
invited rebel groups terrorist
organizations and US allies and
adversaries killing nearly a half
million civilians while millions more
have lost their homes or fled the
country throughout this destruction the
United States has debated its
involvement with little consensus beyond
an assessment that Syria is a mess
President Obama's National Security
Council spokesperson Tommy Vietor says
quote the Obama administration the
international community handed Trump an
incredibly difficult situation in Syria
with no great options but the reality is
Assad has been killing innocent
civilians with impunity for six or seven
years now
for the US Syria presents a complicated
challenge defeating Isis countering
Russia and Iran both allies of the Assad
regime while somehow promoting stability
by the summer of 2011 then President
Obama declared the time had come for
Assad to step aside one year later he
set a threshold for deeper US military
involvement in Syria a red line for us
is we start seeing a whole bunch of
chemical weapons moving around or being
utilized that would change my calculus
one year after that Assad crosses that
line a preliminary US government report
says the Assad regime killed more than
1,400 Syrians in a gas attack President
Obama decided against a unilateral air
strike he deferred to Congress and
eventually focused u.s. airpower on Isis
in Syria
to remove Assad's chemical weapons the
u.s. turned to Assad's ally Russia
securing an agreement there can be no
games no room for avoidance or anything
less than full compliance
by the Assad regime though the United
Nations determined chemical attacks
continued Tommy Vietor tweeted quote
shipping out 1,300 metric tons of
weapons-grade chemicals was a major
development obviously they didn't get it
all
chlorine wasn't covered Trump was handed
a mess but also hasn't deterred Assad
last April another chemical attack in
northern Syria days later the Trump
administration struck the Assad regime
officials say the next US response in
Syria whatever it is would be
coordinated as administration officials
continue discussions with European
allies Brett Richardson live at the
State Department rich thank you